when I think of of the religion of gun
ownership in this country and you know
the you know NRA support and and the the
greatest hostility to even the most
common-sense measures to you know
protect ourselves from from you know
guns falling into the wrong hands you
know again this could be a bit of a
caricature but I generally think of a
white guys and and not anybody else
right now I would imagine if I were if
our Betty and I would think that that
that is a that a that is a white person
problem more than it is and from any
other community now we just have this we
have this general issue of the fact that
you know we can't uninvent these guns
and we've got more than 300 million of
them on the ground in the US and so
that's just how we get to a place where
it becomes difficult for the wrong
people to get their hands on a gun you
know who knows how we accomplished that
but no there's just this a this is a so
this is the third a a third rail of
political discourse for a reason right
because it's not easily amenable to a
socio-economic analysis or any other
analysis I mean you can get you go into
you know Latino areas in the same cities
with the same socio-economic
characteristics and you don't have the
same level of violence right so it's not
it's just a you know it's just something
that's not being talked about and to
talk about it if you have the if your
skin is the wrong color brands you as a
bigot and yet my only my concern in
talking about it is twofold my concern
is it would be really nice to have fewer
murders in this country right I mean I
you know every time you hear about
people getting shot you know both those
who died and those who live with
injuries I mean that is just an awful
you know intolerable status quo to be
you know not changing
and then there's just the larger issue
of what this what the taboos around this
conversation does to our political
discourse I mean i-i've you this is yet
another reason why we have someone like
Trump because the people who support
Trump know they're being lied to right I
mean we had that you in the run-up to
the election we had this this kind of
hysteria around you know police violence
and you know the shootings of young
black men now some of those cases were
awful right where you know it was
clearly a you know utter you know
sadistic malpractice on the part of cops
who belong in prison right but some were
you know clearly legitimate shootings
and there was no will on the you know
once you went left of center to speak
honestly about the differences there